[Musique]
voilà
chiocca batterie
mais dans quel ordre
2010 quitté alim
attachez votre ceinture en dresser votre
siège rangez votre tablette
parce que nous allons pas tardé avec les
rams te plaît pour une fois est ce que
tu peux plus clair on va dans l'internet
[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs bienvenue sur un
quart d'heure
[Musique]
hu
wall regarde-moi sous ces machins et les
plus beaux miracle que j'ai jamais vu de
toute ma vie
bienvenue au bar de recherche que
puis-je vous aide à trouver aujourd'hui
bain moussant teint de minuit bain de
foule noms de villes noms de pays non
d'athlètes à la sic
arbalète artichauts j'ai comme
l'impression qu'il essaie de deviner ce
que tu vas dire m'a saisie automatique
est un peu nerveuse ce jour ci attend
l'est trouvez moi un site internet qui
déchire bien des livres aux jeunes et
qu'un seul résultat et princesses et des
personnages de dessins animés
tu vas le cuir revenait salit on se
calme et puis je suis une princesse mozy
et quel genre de princesses et tu ta
chevelure est magique non humains sont
magiques
non tu parti avec les animaux non
content a empoisonné non ensorcelé n'ont
enlevé et séquestré
vous êtes sûr que ça va ou faut que
j'appelle la police est ce que les gens
pensent que tous les problèmes se sont
réglés parce qu'un homme fort et
puissant a surgi dans ta vie ouais mais
comme ça se fait d'ailleurs c'est une
vraie princesse
[Musique]